what are we doing tickling technically
sounds like tickle tickle
I like this have you got a snippet for
oh sure I can't wait into a trip and
fall and break my this is really
dangerous
it's like doing Jacob's Ladder in
football I know how to do the electric
slide you know how hard can it be
do people who like get hurt a lot when
they first present yes okay you're not
he not again yeah it's a lot of power
seems like with an intense top going man
who will take my feet out
yeah I gotta be kidding me yo well let's
say that these guys I don't know this is
not really my thing
people can do this or a genius this
that's Filipinos man okay I'm scared I
don't like it did I do it cuz I'm doing
it I think I was free style oh my god
what's harder than I thought for sure
but I think with a little bit of
practice it's pretty fun actually I feel
like you have to be one with the bamboo
yeah you have to be a totally one with
the bamboo and it was a bamboo and you
are the same they're hardcore hardcore
even they're like simple ceremonial
dances could kill you
this dance could kill you and they have
children doing it it could it could kill
you if you're here in your [ __ ] boat
they have volcanoes in the Philippines
yeah places have okay nose